I got social anxiety but you're like
sand next to me yeah social anxiety when
you kiss me I can't breathe the internet
loves to come for Lindsay Lohan and
today is well no exception
[Music]
about us first of all I know it's hard
to tell what exactly you're watching but
Lindsey uploaded a video to her
Instagram set to her new song xanax now
the video isn't formatted for YouTube or
VEVO or anything of the sorts nor is it
made for Spotify vertical yes I can take
home on trip for the night just for the
night
I mean it seems Lindsay kinda pieced it
together herself it's just the shots she
chose they're cropped weird they're kind
of blurry
there are even filtered Instagram videos
in there
stay away from you but you get me hi the
weirdest part of the video though is how
it ends it's like losing my hair this
isn't my keep dare Lindsay posted the
video to her IG TV and wrote quote this
video is a compilation of vignettes of
life family love the process of moving
forward and letting go of the past to
live and be happy free of fear just to
be grateful and open our eyes to our
opportunities instead of numbing the
mind whatever you say but Leila's fans
are loyal a s I love music and I love
entertaining eg was with Lindsay in
January she had this to say about a
future and music your multitasking a lot
what about music
my sister singing right now so I really
want to support her and that we were
just talking about this ever see was
came out could you guys collaborate and
do something together her and I've
talked about that my song bossy is this
song for the show but that's something
we've talked about her name but while
we're waiting for that song to drop
Lindsay is getting dragged for another
musical moment her reaction to the
latest unmasking on Australia's masked
singer oh yeah
if you didn't know Lindsay is a judge on
that version of the show
anyways fans took notice that she had no
idea who Big Brother Australia host
Gretel Killeen was I don't either and
they had a lot to say but hey you can't
win them all
alright guys that's it for today what do
you think of Lindsay's new music video
let me know and for all the latest on
Leeloo stick with ET until next time I'm
Katie Krauss and bye for now